for you here's why you should ask for at
least
a five percent raise right now aorta
okay
so this article basically says and i
agree with so there's a i'm gonna read
some of this but i'm also going to give
you a little opinion on this now's the
time to start thinking about year end
races now
okay it's the end of the fiscal year
that's according to danielle dimartino
booth you can find her on valuetainment
economics she's a boss babe she says at
the end of the fiscal year now is the
time to start asking for raises right
q4 starts tomorrow yeah so many
companies are basically having internal
discussions or battles override how much
we pay in people these conversations
they're brewing these conversations are
being had internally
externally internally and externally
right but there's good news
there's good news for all you guys at
home for the first time in a long time
in well over a decade
the power goes to the people boom the
power with the people the workers
the employees may actually have the
upper hand you guys at home listening
you call the shots yeah you do you're
the bosses now not technically but you
got some you got some uh
some boss techniques on your side so
here's the deal on average this is
something you guys should know
on average
you can expect
salary increases to be about 3 percent a
year so going into 2022 you can expect a
three percent increase in your salary
okay cool
you talk about inflation inflation is
two to three percent a year okay you've
been there tenure three percent is very
normal but
not so fast
now you should go for at least five
percent
why is that you say here's the deal
the economy is finally emerging out of
covet lockdowns workers have been
basically collecting unemployment
collecting stimulus checks saying [ __ ]
you pay me i ain't going back to the
office
pay me okay what else
cost of living is rising rents have gone
up real estate's gone up right consumer
price index cpi you ever heard of that
cpi it's jumped five percent in the last
year inflation's here
things are brewing
things are freaking brewing
and there's a strong job market
all this stuff all these headwinds
tailwinds it's all going on
not right now david
sit your ass down after the show
[Laughter]
but anyway the workers have the power
now i'm happy i'm happy for my people
out there watching the show because a
lot of people watching the show are
saying i want to get better with my
money you know where to get better with
your money make more money
save more money
invest that money
so here's what i'm saying if three
percent is average
and five percent is what they're asking
for check your skill set at the door how
are you doing are you the best at what
you do maybe you're in line for a ten
percent raise
maybe if you're making 100 grand there's
an extra 10 grand that's coming your way
maybe if you're making 40 now you get
50.
show them what you're worth show a skill
set i asked the biz doc this guy
consults i said i said
if someone's going to ask you for a
raise oh
right he goes oh yeah you know people
have asked me for raises before but
giggity giggity he's a great guy
he says look here's a couple of here's
ideas to throw you away
bring a list of the projects that you've
completed cool okay what's the market
paying for your job like what's what's
out there but above all
he says communicate loyalty
don't say well down the street they're
paying da da da da
your employee will be like well then go
on you go down the street yeah he says
look
i want to be here
i don't want to go anywhere right
god forbid something did happen with our
company and i got laid off
here's what i'm seeing out there i don't
want to go anywhere
you know your your boss your employer
wants loyalty that's you know
not to get all political right they want
loyalty
so
you come to them with stats with figures
you show them how you've helped the
bottom line
it's not an emotional thing logical
thing and then he says you asked this
you asked this
is there anything i've been able
is there let me let me let me do that
again he says this
ask this question is there anything i
have been unable to deliver this year
that you wanted me to deliver
boom
and then you wait
and if the answer is well no you've
you've been great
well there you have your answer you
should probably get your raise at that
point you brought the stats
you brought um comparison
you're communicating loyalty you've
delivered
you asked the question is there anything
i haven't delivered right if the answer
is yes bro you actually have [ __ ] up
tremendously
you probably would have known that going
in anyway so now is the time to
reevaluate getting your raise okay
fourth quarter starting right now the
end of the fiscal year holidays are
approaching we got halloween coming up
thanksgiving christmas budgets are
getting uh you know completed right now
go get that five percent raise go get
that 10 raise go get what you're worth
now
is the time
for it get in there i feel like i was
do it
above
just
do it i mean honestly what's in like
what's like the worst case scenario to
say no
go go in there ask what you want what
you deserve what you think you deserve
like you said with facts with numbers
with loyalty yeah ask that question and
like worst case scenario they just said
no and then you're like yeah
okay and then you just keep well look i
um
it's been a while since i've asked for a
raise because i make commissions so
maybe i say look on this deal whatever
like you know i don't i don't have a
salary give me a bigger piece of that
comment peter piece that pie that's it
but regardless um you wanted them to
know that you're going to be there from
the long haul you believe in the company
you're not going anywhere and this
investment in me
yeah yeah that's going gonna pay off
[Music]
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broke
[Music]
you